bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono pani j
oggi andiamo avanti contro my thing
erano un secolo che non facevo video un
episodio su questa serie praticamente
consiste nel disegnare una parola che
apparirà scritta che adesso vedrete e
tutti gli altri la devono indovinare la
particolarità di questa serie è che io
sto giocando con alcuni di voi come
appunto nel primo episodio
adesso adesso magari fatemi di segnare
prima poi vi spiego meglio allora sono
io a lezione per primo facciamo una
giraffa e fattivo raga per chi non mi
conosce
sono veramente un fenomeno nel disegnare
le cose allora la giraffa e gialla
facciamo un arancione mi sento però oggi
allora facciamo ecco che cazzo sono raga
sono un fenomeno c'è voi vi aspettate
picasso io sono di più guardate che
lineamenti e cioè sembra un dinosauro
cazzo però vabbè aspettate che li faccia
le chiazze
ok e fate raga sono veramente un
fenomeno guardate raia guardate che cosa
epica sta uscendo bene perfetto 1
indovinato sono un'artista ragazzo non
artista c'è poco da dire
ebbene sì ma che cazzo
raga questa e da screen fantastica dopo
questo inizio veramente a livello
artistico
posso spiegarvi di cosa si tratta allora
ci sono io ovviamente sono fa vj e tutti
gli altri sono dei partecipanti e siete
praticamente voi come si fa a
partecipare basta scrivere aspettate un
attimo che faccia la sola parola madonna
madonna prima è stato anche spiegando il
bello è che stava anche spiegando son
riuscito a capire
vi abbattuti tutte ok e vabbè per poter
partecipare laga praticamente dovette
mettere mi piace la pagina di facebook e
come non i video trovate nella
descrizione come dico sempre senza
preavviso e quando decido di registrare
lo scrivo su facebook sulla pagina di
facebook appunto
e cos'è questa di preparare lo aspettate
un attimo ok sofia sto scrivendo quello
che scrivono gli altri è ok
le gag madonna modo madonna madonna
madonna madonna ma come cazzo faccio
essere così intelligente si va beh
ragazzi poi perdo sempre mi vanto sempre
come non so cosa poi faccio una figura
di merda va beh grazie bella
se riesco a finire la frase prima di
finire l'episodio magari è meglio per
poter partecipare
niente mettete mi piaceva pagina di
facebook e ogni tanto praticamente
quando mi gira che devo registrare do my
thing lo scrivo mettendo il link per
partecipare ovviamente ci sono soltanto
sei posti però comunque farò tanti
episodi quindi magari ci sarà più
possibilità di partecipare va beh la
chiudo qui perché sennò mi sto
prolungando veramente tantissimo sono
primo con 9 punti
cos'è sta roba sembra una zattera cos'è
è una è una bandiera flag cioè io sto
scrivendo quello che scrivono gli altri
ssss un cazzo zattera raft raft raft
raft madoff a nonna vada questa questa
me l'hanno data perché sono troppo forte
dio mio che tre su tre e faccio pagare
raga c'è una cosa assurda
non ci posso credere veramente sono
primo e non capita mai io perdo sempre
facendo figure di merda ma stavolta
incredibilmente sono primo raga non
potete nulla contro di me inutile che ci
provate ma fa dj qui va beh meglio che
la smetta di vantarmi perché so già che
tanto perdo lo stesso ok questo è
bellissimo mi piace tanti spiano forte
pianoforte non è un pianoforte come vi è
venuto in mente pianoforte
ok sinceramente questa l'ho capita a
parte che io c'è una fantasia che fa
veramente pena fa vj ok devo scrivere fa
vj no letter cosa come fossero la legge
ma cos'è favi j.lewis oc'era che ho
vinto la prima partita è durata
praticamente due minuti niente perché ho
passato metà del tempo a spiegare va
bene direi di partire allora tocca a me
facciamo
wave honda vediamo se riesco a disegnare
delle onde decenti ok bene ho finito
vabbè cerchiamo di fare una cosa un po
più decente alcuni l'hanno capito hanno
già scritto mare però ovviamente non è
male ma sono le onde perfetto c'è un
genio che è riuscito a scriverlo ragas
ma dove le visite delle onde così belle
ragazze veramente io i miei disegni di
dovrei mettere al louvre perché
veramente c'è io sono un artista mancato
qui va bè ragala smetto che è meglio
va beh questa è questo è il domino
domino sembra domino domino
non ci posso credere non ci posso
credere non ci posso credere
ma che cazzo mi succede oggi
raga io e tutti quanti poi abbiamo
un'intesa che veramente un qualcosa di
assurdo sono primo incredibile posso
provare a vincere anche la seconda ma so
già che tanto non la vinco ma va bene è
questa una linea linea banana nera black
banana
ok perfetto a rodero adroid street
stritt street no non è street
ma come si dice strada strada strada si
dice street e poi come rolls royce
no non ero al quarantatreesimo strada
che l'ho capito ma non funziona ragadi
giuro che questa non la so non mi viene
in mente cosa vuol dire cosa voleva dire
tu tubo flessibile
va beh questa è una lampada l'ho capito
capita subito l'ump l'ump madonna prima
non ci posso credere raga non ci credo 8
punti in vantaggio arriva fa vj viva fa
vj che è in vantaggio veramente raga non
ho parole
mi devo veramente godere questo momento
raga perché non ricapiterà mai più nei
prossimi episodi che io riesca ad essere
in vantaggio per così tanto tempo
comunque va beh questa è una scatola
grigia
no cos'è sembra un trampolino piscina
pool
secondo me io l'altro ieri mi dovevo
proporre per essere eletto papa non l'ho
fatto perché non pensavo di avere tanta
fortuna però se l'avessi saputo adesso
l'avrei fatto perché non lo so mi sto
stupendo di me stesso se non capisco
neanche perchè li azzecco però vabbè
vi giuro che non sono in chiamava beh
perché lo sentirete ma non sono in
chiamata con nessuno telephone telephone
ha solo tre parole ok il perché cazzo me
l'ha data buona c'è non lo capirà forse
se scrivi un qualcosa di simile tela
conta buona lo stesso cioè non lo so non
è che qualsiasi cosa scrivo adesso me la
conta buona forse per questo che sto
vincendo alla prima scrivere nutella
ok no non funziona allora evidentemente
non è così questo è un diplomato
diplomato graduate è un pittore un
pittore a è un piccolo no che cos'è il
comando e jack sparso jack sparrow gex
falso ho scritto con due elle va beh
ecco mandare qualche sono comandante
pirata sailor cosa vuol dire sei lo e
sailor moon
vabbè ho vinto ho vinto la seconda
partita raga io non capisco come faccio
a vincerle
vabbè 2 su 3 love inter ne faccia ancora
un'altra perché ovviamente il video
durato poco non ci posso veramente
credere ho guardato due medaglie d'oro 2
medaglie d'oro neanche usain bolt era
vinta e così tante veramente raga non ho
parole
ok raga tocca di nuovo a me
questo è peanut butter cosa e burro di
noccioline praticamente era gay la
nutella
sognavo questo momento adesso scommetto
quello che volete che tutti quanti
scrivere tenutella lo so già però vabbè
lo faccio lo stesso allora questo è il
barattolo cos'è sta roba
sembra un tostapane non un barattolo di
nocciolino a sto punto io ci scrivo
veramente nutella
vediamo chi lo indovinano tel nutella
raga scusate sono andato a [ __ ] il
disegno però per una volta che mi capita
in un episodio che faccio un qualcosa di
simile per lo meno alla nutella
dovevo farlo perdonatemi va beh più o
meno c'entrava comunque qualcuno ci
poteva arrivare ma non potevano
disegnare la nutella
andiamo con il prossimo raga voglio
vedere che cosa vi inventate stavolta
ok questa questo non è un fantasma ghost
no
oddio è veramente un fanta altro uno
space spectre spectre no
che cos'è sta roba eh lo so mi sembra un
po che ma è una suora come si dice sua
la suora si assiste ok sisters bene c'è
chi l'ha indovinata io questo non l'ho
capita sinceramente non ha veramente la
cama che è sta roba cioè non si capisce
a scream
ma perché ma facevi mib atti bastava
disegnare john ed eri a posto e tra
l'altro raga vi stavo dicendo io questo
episodio qui dietro my thing non me ne
sono uscito oggi così ho deciso di fare
draw my thing l'ho fatto perché domani
deve uscire un episodio speciale e non
volevo che uscisse oggi quindi ho detto
oggi di oggi stiamo do my thing e domani
uscirà questo episodio che è stato
aspettando tutti da tanto si va bel
giorno e l'avete capito ma non ve lo
dico lo stesso cos'è sta roba è l'anello
mancante della catena dell'evoluzione o
cosa e dumbo e dumbo dumbo oppure pink
elephant o in dove appena indovinato
pink elephant ma come cazzo è possibile
ma veramente ragazzi non ci posso
credere come mi è venuto in mente pink
elephant non lo so però non sono stato
prima indovinarlo lo stesso fare i j
ma vige allora indoviniamo fa vj gran
figo ma vabbè dai batteri scafa vj
versus nutella po vj versus nutella chi
è che la spunta la spunto io
no non ha spunto io cosa devo indovinare
qui è di tre parole prova a scrivere
qualcosa a caso dog
non lo so oddio l'ha indovinata a caso
sono riuscito a vincere anche
indovinando la parola a caso non ci
credo ma come possiede e nonostante
questo sono ancora primo sono secondo se
vinco la terza la mando a guinness world
record non ci posso credere laga anche a
caso riesco indovinare io veramente non
so più cosa dire
devo vincere questa sento vino questa
dovrei aver vinto questo mi sembra
vagamente steve di happy wales steve non
estimo via meno qualcuno anche scritto
nonno ciak e vabbè basketball but no c'è
chi l'ha indovinato merda basketball
nozze era basket sono riuscito a
sbagliare perché ho sbagliato a scrivere
basketball
e va beh non posso crederci che ho
sbagliato perché non son riuscito a
scrivere basketball ok raga ho preso
comunque due punti sono a pari merito
con giulia gatti batterò inutile che fai
la gradassa perché ti batto vabbè
siamo 5 5 quest'anno c'è anche un altro
che a 5 che questa è l'ultima chi fa
questo ha vinto devo concentrarmi laga
devo concentrarmi utilizzare le mie doti
paranormali foglia è una foglia fire no
è una mano and orologio wroclawek no non
ero già non posso perdere
cos'è sta roba è un braccialetto bra bra
bracciale braccialetto cos'è
braccialetto non è quello no hanno
indovinata no perché è una vena come si
cenava in vain wengen troppo tardi
troppo tardi o ancora no non ci posso
credere non ci posso credere
sono arrivato secondo la maledetta
giulia gatto 97 va beh sì ho battuto fa
brava brava brava hai battuto il
veggente va beh io direi che due primi
posti e un secondo posto non mi capiterà
mai più nella storia di dro my thing
vabbè da io direi che per questo
episodio posso chiudere qua ho voluto
fare questo perché domani devo far
uscire appunto l'episodio speciale che
state aspettando tutti quanti da da un
bel pezzo motivo evan capito chiama non
lo dico lo stesso per chi non l'ha
capito io direi che per questo episodio
posso chiudere qua se volete partecipare
alla prossima puntata basta mettere mi
piace alla pagina di facebook che
trovate in estinzione come in ogni video
e quando registrano una puntata di dro
my thing lo scriverò li appunto i primi
che partecipano appariranno appunto del
prossimo video
direi di finire qua prima di prolungarmi
troppo se vi è piaciuto video come al
solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook che come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e
noi ci vediamo in un prossimo video
bella ragazzi